The Economist comes out with the story
talking about following the Supreme
Court decision of Dobbs versus Jackson
Women's Health Organization ruling which
allowed states to ban abortion and
demand the vasectomy surge in the summer
of 2022 Dr Doug Stein a urologist saw
registrations for vasectomies almost
tripled the week after the ruling
insurance claims data indicates 17
increase in procedures and a six-month
following the ruling after a with a 29
percent increase between July and
September while the number of
vasectomies have been gradually
increasing in recent years the rate of
Americans who have un undergone the
procedure is lower than it was 20 years
ago men who were motivated by Dobbs
ruling cited various reasons for
choosing vasectomy including concerns
about limited access to abortion as a
backup contraception method Fierce that
vasectomy could be outlawed next in a
sense of solidarity with women vasectomy
is being is seen as a sacrifice that
eases the burden of contraception
response ability from women and is often
associated with gender quality equality
what a noble cause so when are you guys
getting yours done yeah I mean I don't
have any Adam you're trying to have a
kid I'm trying to have one so I'm gonna
wait I'm impregnating everybody out
there yeah that's four my brother any
thoughts on this crazy of course of
course this is going to be a very
controversial controversial take okay
it's a brace for impact
only men can have vasectomies that's
what yeah yeah only men women cannot
have your psychophobic transphobia hey
it is what it is you're a phobic just
like only women can have babies I said
it I don't know what no yeah no no no
I'm taking that stance right you know I
actually had a conversation we had a
whole debate about this Rolo uh Rolo
tomasi shout out to him he made a whole
uh shitstorm tweet storm out there
basically saying the quickest path to
being a high value man was to do the
following seven things and number three
I believe was get a vasectomy and it was
very controversial people were like what
are you talking about why would do men
get a vasectomy and basically he says
you know there was a whole checklist of
things
and essentially the what and he
highlighted the quickest path is not
rushing to have kids not rushing to have
a family focusing on yourself focusing
on not having kids focus on your money
focusing on all that which I can
appreciate because I've sort of followed
that path and now that I've made my
money have my network things are good
Life's good I'm fully prepared fully
ready to uh basically utilize my
non-vasectomy to the ladies out there
taking applications and I think I think
that the the next situation is yeah I
would like to have a family and and I
fully agree with kind of what he's
saying and I wouldn't take what he was
saying too literally I don't think
people are rushing to genuinely get
vasectomies but not having kids and not
starting a family at least in your 20s
and even in your 30 30s early 30s I
think is important and then the next
phase I think it is very important to be
a family man well as you know Patrick he
told us you're you're leaving this
weekend so is there any possibility you
want to tell everybody where you're
going and maybe you might pull the
trigger you might come back I'm going
back to Romania to see tape we're gonna
go have great time we did the filming
now I'm invited back and there's a lot
of uh great opportunity great success
so we'll see
yeah but Tom you waited until you're
quiet played this clip with doctor so
watch this video I love it I love this
slip younger boys who might not have
their own money to go buy tampons
provided free in the bathroom it's it's
a huge box men do not menstruate only
women men straight now you can call
yourself whatever you want a trans men
do menstrual non-binary people only
women operating is not exclusive yes it
is women no it's not yes it is
if your promised homes are XX and you're
young you menstruate if you're XY you
don't correct but what about trans men
and non-violence we're not putting a
whole group they're women dressed as men
you are not a man camo you pretend to be
a man that's okay that's perfectly fine
live your life tell me what a man is
well what's a man to you you define a
man for me you have chromosomes that are
X and Y that's what a man is so why are
we just looking at the the the the
science of this as a design when when
we've learned sex and gender identity
the completely different things
are born with the sexual reproductive
organizations
well I don't accept that distinction you
have to argue for it you're just giving
a conclusion you're you're just making
it up people the people the truth
is
so comfortable people if you want to
identify in any way you can you're free
to do so but that is not mean that the
rest of us have to join that illusion
you disagree I disagree with you and so
you call it hate there's no hate in my
heart at all so that's you are being
hateful when you tell somebody that
identifies as a man that they're not a
man
aren't you I tell you I love that he's
wearing a pink shirt I love it
but I got I'm a fifth grade teacher he's
playing with his chest he's like you
know what you don't you don't got a
vagina you know what's amazing you're a
guy I'm a fifth grade teacher come on I
love him my new hero number one you know
at the end that he was going to be
called hate and right wing extreme it's
like he's like I'm a fifth grade teacher
here buddy why is his voice so important
because this guy deals with
nine-year-olds and 10 year olds who
think they're unicorns and princesses
and Peter Pan and astronauts and they're
living in Fantasyland and they are not
so he knows how to identify people who
are just living in Never Never Land and
being like uh I know Scotty that you
think you're an astronaut and you're
wearing that little or you think you're
a T-Rex you're just a boy so I'm gonna
allow you to think you are you're just a
boy same thing as the [__] out there
you're just a man dressing up in skirts
yeah and and at the end of the day do
you I I hope you get the right because
you know the gender does for you it's
meant whatever they need to do do and
that's what and that's a great point
that he made I disagree doesn't mean I
hate and like we say listen like leave
the kids let the kids make up their own
decision leave them alone you're
transphobic labels put on you and you
hate them it's like bro do your thing
that's the definition of transphobic is
the hatred of trans people nobody hates
Trend people no saying hey I don't think
you're an actual woman I think you still
got your dick yeah uh and I don't think
you have a period I don't hate you I'm
just kind of telling you the truth the
facts don't give a [__] about your
feelings exactly they really don't you
know Bill Maher what was that four or
five months ago did a beautiful diatribe
and um he just kind of laid it out at
the very end of it he said me personally
when I was young I wanted to be a pirate
and I'm so glad my parents didn't send
me out for eye removal
that was how he summed it up exactly he
said it's a phase and everything is a
phase in kids and I think in all
seriously made a great point I I fully
agree I think in all seriousness the
number one thing is you got you guys
want to dress up and do your little
thing stay away from the kids
oh here's with Prager amazing even
better
is that the clip or no no no no it's
it's
yeah where he goes through this you want
to give a hot take on this no I don't
have a hot ticket it's Common Sense man
it's just you know you can keep trying
to push this down people's throat but
guess what you're starting to look like
clowns is what you're starting to look
like absolute clowns and who looks even
bigger of a clown you know who who's the
guy that works at uh what is the guy's
name who works at MSNBC he does the
elections man I wish
no no no give me the names he's like
what is it with these guys that do you
know what studies show that you know the
whole thing about there's only two
different Sexes that's actually not true
do you know recent Studies have shown
I'm listening to this because I'm like
do you realize like you're a pretty
credible guy to say I'll find it and
I'll give it to you guys Chuck Todd
Chuck Todd said something
but Chuck Todd did say something along
the lines no no it's chucked out it's
chucked out that's it Let's Meet the
Press Chuck tired University of Miami
[Music]
and he goes it's not just about like
it's like things have changed and
there's different and the guy was like
no no I don't know yeah it was vivec
this was it pat right yeah yeah but
don't do the whole one one minute and 51
seconds see if you can find a shorter
version of it are you confident okay I
found it I'm gonna text it to you I'm
gonna text it to you I lost all respect
for him you gotta hear this this is like
how can you even say something like that
and have still have credibility uh I
texted it to you
rob let me know if you got it it's it's
mind-bogging did you lose respect for
him be honest I I don't know if I had it
in the first place to lose it like there
needs to be some respect to lose it yeah
when you when you continuously say stuff
that makes zero sense you just lose
credibility that's also as simple as
that watch this I can't believe this
would be back in Vivek is sitting there
saying like you work for this company
how did you get a job for this company
watch this go ahead thank you
I love it are you confident that you
know that gender uh is uh as binary as
you're describing it are you confident
it isn't a spectrum
well there's there's two X chromosomes
if you're a woman an X and A Y that
means
there's a lot of scientific research out
there that says gender is a spectrum
Chuck I respectfully disagree gender
dysphoria for most of our history all
the way through the DSM-5 has been
characterized as a mental health
disorder and I don't think it's
compassionate to affirm that I think
that's cruelty when a kid is crying out
for help what they're asking for is you
gotta ask the question of what else is
going wrong at home what else is going
on at school let's be compassionate and
get to the heart of that rather than
playing this game as though we're
actually changing our medical
understanding for the last time I go
back to this the lack that a Chuck Todd
what says that there's people that
watched this who are regular people and
say well I'm never going to have a show
on TV especially at a company like that
that guy probably knows what he's
talking about what there's more than two
genders no yeah
where is The credibility for something
like that what would make him say that
but real talk to what make what makes
him say that he's reading off his notes
and his chart why would you even say
that the clown show because to keep his
job he's a wind-up toy soldier for the
left looks just to kind of so so all of
this kind of ties all together with a
company we are all deeply concerned
about and I think we need to they're you
know the way they're going right now
their funeral is coming soon so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]